will we see 10 inflation in the official
cpi number in the united states in the
next three years you think i think we
will unless they rigged the numbers
again i mean i wouldn't put it past them
but assuming they leave the cpi the way
it is probably we might see 10 next year
is inflation going to get worse in the
coming year well it has to get worse and
and in fact and again when you're
talking about price increases
you're measuring the consequence of
inflation the inflation is the expansion
of the money supply and we know money
supply is going to keep expanding
they're about to raise the debt ceiling
right so we can keep uh going deeper
into debt you know i always laugh
whenever they talk about it janet yellen
you know when she testified the other
day she said six times the government's
gonna be bankrupted
the funny thing is she said we have to
raise the debt ceiling because it's
important that we pay our bills in full
on time well if we paid our bills in
full on time we'd have no debt right the
reason we have a debt is because we
don't pay our bills at all we borrow
money so that we don't have to pay our
bills and what janet yellen really means
is that we need to raise the debt
ceiling because we can't pay our bills
we can't pay our bills to take more on
more we have to take on more debt can i
ask a serious question and yeah i i'm
scared to ask you this because i'm going
to give you like all the ammunition in
the world
if i
am taking money from one
investor or lender to pay back
the original yes blender ponzi well
there's two ways to look at it it's
called refinancing people doing
mortgages all the time right it's also
called a ponzi scheme if they're
investors that i'm not necessarily
refinancing yes i'm literally just
playing like a yes it is a ponzi scheme
that's why bernie madoff said that the
united states was running the world's
biggest ponzi scheme and that what he
did was nothing compared to that and i i
used to look at his defense because no
but he just mentioned it like hey come
on i mean like he wasn't saying he said
they do it
but this was the thing did he really say
that was really his defense yes and then
the new york times wrote this piece and
they mentioned it and they said well you
know bernie madoff doesn't have any
credibility right so and i used to joke
and say wait a minute wait a minute he's
got credibility on one thing yeah
right so if he says he's trying to pull
up
yes exactly that's why i used to joke we
should have made him secretary of the
treasury
the whole nature of what we were doing
you know that's pretty good yeah and you
know because but the thing is the
government janet yellen when she tells
everybody that if we don't raise the
debt ceiling we're going to default
that's an admission it's a ponzi scheme
right bernie madoff would never be dumb
enough to admit he was running a ponzi
scheme right that's ponzi 101. you keep
it quiet right you don't tell everybody
it's a ponzi scheme because they're not
gonna okay
all right so that's the debt let's go to
social security because one of the
things that i'm very interested all
right wait before you do that
i forgot to finish to answer the
question as to why the inflation is
going to be worse
on a cpi
look at um producer prices okay producer
prices
2021
up more than consumer prices
so businesses were seeing their prices
costs rise
more than
what they passed on to their customers
now why was that it's because a lot of
businesses were reluctant to raise
prices they're worried about losing
sales to competitors and they were told
that it's all transitory okay we'll take
a hit for a few months it's transitory
we don't want to reprice everything and
then have to change the prices so
businesses kind of absorbed the rising
prices and and took a hit in their
margins
uh but i think by 2021 or 2022 rather
a lot of these businesses are going to
throw in the towel and they're going to
say you know what we got to pass this on
uh it's not temporary
and i think you're going to see
businesses much more
willing to raise prices in 2022 than
they were in 2021
and is this where you see corporate
executives on their uh earnings calls
being like oh we raised prices and like
the customers liked it like it was
basically like that's basically what
people have said they've been like oh we
raised prices and the market accepted it
right they're not saying they liked it
they're just saying they accepted our
higher prices they tolerated it
uh and therefore now they feel
emboldened to do more of it because
they've seen like hey we did a little
bit we raised three or four percent
nobody left actually in some cases
demand is even higher and so if we raise
it five or six percent from here then if
nobody leaves we can just continue to
play this game yeah i mean they're going
to raise prices as much as they can i
mean in general businesses want to
maximize profits and so the reason you
don't keep raising prices is eventually
you lose sales
but if all of your competitors are
facing the same cost problems that you
have
when you raise prices other people have
to raise prices too what ultimately
happens though
as you really start to raise prices
significantly it does impact demand
because not everybody can afford the
higher prices and then what happens is
businesses end up reducing capacity so
they can achieve their profitability at
a lower scale and then prices really
start to go up because now supply is
coming down because fewer businesses are
providing these products or services
uh and and you really get the spiral but
what's driving it all is the money it's
more money being created i mean they
keep talking about the supply side
problems i was you know just getting a
kick out of powell's testimony
because did you watch was that your
super bowl were you were you sitting
there and you you had a beer and like uh
some steak and
i didn't have refreshments or anything
but um but powell was like well because
somebody said to him well what did you
get wrong you know now that he's saying
it's not trans story and powell said
well you know
we got one thing wrong and that was this
supply problem the supply i mean and he
said but you know in fairness nobody
could have predicted this this was crazy
it came out of left field i mean nobody
could have realized that the effect of
the pandemic would have been like supply
chain bottlenecks and i'm like what is
this guy serious i mean
so
you basically shut down
the entire economy right all these
factories close
you furlough all the workers you
literally stop making stuff
and now you're surprised that there's a
shortage of stuff you're not making it
anymore how could there not be a supply
chain problem i pointed it out on my
podcast in march of 2020 as soon as this
happened i said i don't know why people
are talking about covet as being
deflationary this is inflation on
steroids because not only are we
flooding the world with money
we're stopping the production of goods i
mean we we're having less stuff and more
money to buy it this is like you know
double inflation uh so
inflation and
you know inflation is more money and
chasing less stuff well when factories
shut down they're not producing stuff